der hauptgrund wieso derzeit keine
minecraft folgen kommen und zwar arbeite
ich derzeit an einen alten männer lieben
freund und herzlich willkommen hier zu
diesem kleinen real live video wie lockt
hier am donnerstag
und zwar habe ich mir einfach gedacht da
ist das halt immer diese frage im raum
gestellt wurde hey was ist mit dem
mannschaft das ist mit der serie wieso
hast du nie beendet wie das vieh posiert
und außerdem hey das ist ja die video
days wo bist du da wo kann man nicht
hassen autogrammstunde blabla weil ich
mir gedacht ich beantworte die beiden
fragen heute einfach mal ich hab hier
bei the way gerade mein konzert an
das ziehe ich eigentlich meistens so zum
schlaf man einfach weil das natürlich
ist ich finde auch mittlerweile ich habe
sonst war das grau an aber ich finde
dass sie mittlerweile von dem von der
farbgebung eigentlich noch cooler
also wenn ihr es euch kaufen die zuerst
mal auf die sache mit dem video das ein
weil das gerade halt aktuell ist und
zwar ist heute donnerstag wenn ihr das
video seht das heißt heute morgen bin
ich nach berlin geflogen und ich werde
dort bleiben bis zum sonntagnachmittag
das heißt ich bin beide tage auf dem bio
day ist also freitag der erste mai und
samstag der zweite mal werde ich beide
tage auf die bio days eine zweite sache
ich habe keine autogrammstunde ich hatte
zwar eigentlich ein aber die habe ich
abgesagt weil ich habe mir dann noch mal
überlegt so letztes hier auf dem video
ist eine autogrammstunde warst du
wurdest eine stunde lang in sonstiges
zelt gesetzt die tische wurden mit immer
mehr an dem baukran gedrückt hat
teilweise fast gar keine luft mehr
bekommen wenn man da als zuschauer in
dem zimmer drin stand weil man immer auf
zug von hinten gedrückt wurde
dann war es außerdem auch so dass man
danach der stunde danach den anderthalb
stunden oder nach den zwei stunden die
man auch noch einmal thema wird man
daraus getan aus dem zelt und dann haben
sind dann wieder neue leute rein
gegangen was natürlich völlig normales
weil anderen ort die auf autogramme
geben allerdings stehe halt leute wegen
dir vor dem zelt und warten auf dich und
angela winkler ausgehandelt haben die
quasi nicht das bekommen was sie wollten
deswegen möchte ich da gar keine großen
versprechen versprechen machen
ich sage einfach so ich bin die beiden
tage irgendwo im gelände am rumlaufen
und wenn ihr mich seht können mich gerne
ansprechen und sagen hey
kannst du mir vielleicht raufen sie
schreiben oder können vielleicht ein
foto machen oder irgendwie sowas dann
kann ich das gerne alles machen mit euch
von mir aus können wir auch kekse
schenken oder bionade oder was hier auf
wilde also ich finds halt letztes jahr
ist nicht cool mit der organisation von
den autogrammstunden das war echt immer
so ein bisschen dann standen da auch
nachher leute vor dem zelt und haben
geheult weil die nicht mehr zu uns
konnten weil die das zelt schon
zugemacht hatten dann als eine bank zur
blauen plane deswegen ich bin einfach
dieses jahr auf dem video days irgendwo
am rumlaufen und genau das die gleiche
sache auch bezogen auf was anderes und
zwar wurde ich gefragt ob ich mit seinem
komischen bot davor fahren möchte so
roter teppich mäßig habe ich nämlich
auch abgesagt weil ich einfach findet es
youtuber sind youtuber das weist glaube
ich jeder der mit bei twitter folgen
oder das sagen wenn jeder das youtuber
youtuber sind aber jeder kennt meine
meinung von den leuten die mir oft oder
erfolgen weil ich da ja schon vorlauf
getötet habe für mich sind die ph keine
starts ich fühle mich halt als wäre ich
jemand der ganz normal so uni geht und
auch ganz normal zockt und ganz normal
auch gerne youtube videos schaut aber
halt auch gerne welche macht und halt
einfach nur weil mir ein paar mehr leute
dann halt zuschauern als der ein oder
anderen person als es jetzt nicht da ich
dass ich da auf dem video der mit im
boot fahrer vor gefahren werden möchte
oder vor gefahren werden muss deswegen
bin ich da voll dagegen und möchte
pfarrer halt auch nicht mit bode feucht
geht einfach hin ganz normaler besucher
auch und wenn ihr mich seht dann könne
nämlich gerne ansprechen also dass zu
den video days erstmal und alle
aufnahmen die ich machen werde an diesem
wochenende donnerstag heute bis sonntag
in drei tagen alles was ich film werde
also ich bin ja zusammen mit rot pilz
krankhaft und escape wäre da noch was
mit anderen youtuber machen
beispielsweise smart key das ist glaube
ich auch noch bei der party dabei wir
sind auch verschiedene netzwerk partys
eingeladen auf der party von google und
auch ganz viele andere sachen und auch
die heinz steens von dem video der ist
werde ich natürlich alles filmen
allerdings werden diese videos jetzt
nicht heute morgen übermorgen und
sonntag hoch geladen sondern genau eine
woche später das heißt das erste video
kommt nächste woche donnerstag das
zweite video kommt dann dementsprechend
nichts woche freitag also am achten mal
also am 7 8 9 10 mai quasi die videos
jetzt vom 30
weil ich einfach ganz simpel aus dem
grund ich schreibe nächste woche montag
und donnerstag klausur und da habe ich
mich dann einfach keinen bock dann auch
noch videos zu steigen deswegen möchte
ich mich da voll auf die uni
konzentrieren und dann lernen in der
zeit und die videos kommen dann quasi
danach also die videos von mir meine
aufnahmen von video day school
zusammengeschnitten zum blabla kommt
quasi eine woche verspätet dann bleibe
ich jetzt noch mal ganz kurz über das
thema wieso keine mai kräftig zu kommen
das kann ich ganz kurz beantworten
es ist nicht weil wir die serie keinen
bock mehr macht es liegt doch nicht
sagen dass ich keine effekte habe ich
habe extrem viele fenster auf lager
allerdings stecke ich gerade meine
komplette arbeit was minecraft fans
angeht in ein großes projekt und dieses
projektes quasi der hauptgrund wieso
derzeit keine minecraft folgen kommen
und zwar arbeitet derzeit an einem buch
an einem buch über minecraft hacks
command slots redstone sachen maps pvp
taktiken in kooperation mit anderen
youtube an also ich habe andere youtuber
gefragt hey ich geht ihren pvp vor
und ja mit dann halt ihre taktik da
verraten und das habe ich da alles im
buch sind da sind auch fakten über mich
drin also sowas wie hey komm crafter
maxi und die games und allgemeinheit
sachen über mich da ist eine persönliche
widmung drin da wird in teilweisen
detail noch am planen das ist irgendwie
so hinkriegen dass ein paar bücher noch
autogramme drin sind weil ich kann
natürlich nicht in jedes buch und
einpacken weil das dann müsst ihr wie
viel zu viel autogramme schreiben und
ich möchte dass ihr das auto kramer
quasi hand geschrieben ist und so weiter
und so fort
also minecraft acts kommen derzeit nicht
nicht weil ich keinen bock drauf habe
oder irgendwie so sondern einfach weil
ich derzeit ein buch darüber schreiben
dürfte ich das jetzt nicht so vorstellen
dass ich hier jeden tag sitze und zehn
seiten davon schreibe wie in seinem
gefängnis oder so nein ich arbeite da
mit einem verlag zusammen und die
besuchen mich relativ häufig bei mir
meiner wohnung und einlagern der relativ
lange und wie kann man das weitermachen
und dann habe ich auf so ein
aufnahmegerät und dann diktieren
die tiere stehen das quasi die schreibt
machen das nach in schriftform und wir
beraten uns über diesen rubriken und so
weiter also natürlich hätte ich den
verlag auch einfach sagen können ja ok
dürften buchen eine serie machen
einfach irgendwas aber dann wäre ich
halt letztendlich dann hätte ich halt so
ein buch aber ich hätte jetzt werk weil
sie nicht von mir
und wer meinen kanal in den letzten
wochen bz monaten verfolgt weiß dass ich
mir bei jedem video unfassbar viel mühe
gebe also ich schneide teilweise an alle
videos schon zwei stunden nur in der
nachbearbeitung brauche ich dafür zählt
also ein bisschen dazu auch dass ich
halt quasi mal so ein bisschen
perfektionistisch war was ich nicht mal
wirklich positiv sehe ich versuche halt
alles perfekt zu machen das ist genauso
auch wenn wir nicht putzen oder so das
sind wirklich auch alles geputzt und
nicht nur das was eigentlich geputzt
werden sollte also ich finde es
eigentlich nicht cool an mir das ist ein
perfektionisten und ich mir bei allem so
mega 54 gebe weil ich glaube ich extrem
wenig freizeit ab in meinem leben aber
genau so ist es halt auch mit dem buch
ich versuche das buch mega cool zu
machen deswegen habe ich dem verlag
gesagt hey ich möchte schon noch
mitbestimmen und hier auch denen man
sagen dass wir das gemacht werden soll
quasi weil ich finde wenn das buch cool
werden soll und jedes auch feiern wollt
und ihr fall der main kanal dann muss es
einfach sein was ich auf feier wenn ihr
versteht was sie mal einer website nur
damals mit dem buch von psalmen des ju
mitbekommen dass er quasi dem verlag
gesagt hat ja macht einfach ein buch
über mich ich vermarkte da schon
irgendwie und letztendlich war das buch
total scheiße das hat er selber dem
video gesagt und dass natürlich die
eigene schuld wenn man dann nicht mehr
mit wirkt aber bei mir ist es halt so
ich möchte daran mitwirken und ich
möchte etwas cooles auf die beine
stellen und es wird halt quasi keine
geschichte irgendwie so eine story die
ich da jetzt sehen oder so sondern weil
sie so zusammen würfeln von fake von
command natürlich auch von geschichten
was sind meine größten rage erlebnis
hatten wir da teilweise in der rubrik
aber ich möchte gar nicht zu viel
verraten
das dauert auch noch ist das ganze
rauskommt ich denke das wird so oktober
november 2015 rauskommen und da kommen
auf jeden fall in zukunft immer noch
mehr informationen dazu und das ist
einfach der grund wieso ich derzeit
keine minecraft wächst macht also nicht
weil ich keinen bock drauf habe oder
weil ich gerne mehr finde oder irgendwie
so sondern ganz einfach weil meine
komplette arbeit und ich natürlich auch
exklusive facts in dem buch anderen
haben möchte
das geht ja quasi alles ins buch gerade
das ist halt schon relativ viel arbeit
ja freunde das war's jetzt hier auch vom
video ich hoffe man hat meiner
augenränder augenränder ich überlege in
letzter zeit so oft bei solchen klaren
wörtern einfach als willig augenränder
kommen lieder und ich bin einfach total
ein kompletter kopf besteht nur noch aus
matte und video four produzieren und bla
deswegen lass euch gefallen dann würde
ich mich über eine wertung freund
schreibt man die kommentare ob ihr euch
auf das buch freund wieder eventuell
ideen habt ob wir eventuell auch sachen
power voll scheiße dass du ein buch
masten brach und sonst würde ich sagen
sehen uns entweder in einem anderen
video morgen wieder oder wir sehen uns
eventuell morgen auch schafft die video
days morgen oder übermorgen das wäre mit
sicherheit recht cool weil im moment bin
ich ja gerade berlin bin ja hier wieder
improvisieren wenn ihr dieses konzert
kaufen möchte steht in der video
beschreibung irgendwo ein link bestimmt
und wenn ihr allgemein öfters wollte ist
wenn mir etwas auf dem herzen wenn ich
euch irgendwie mich mehr mich mit euch
mitteilen möchte und mich dann einfach
ins bett legen und jeweils erzähle dann
schreibt es mir lassen bewertung da und
ich gehe um den morgen mal zum friseur
damit ich nicht mit seiner mehr auf die
video des legal rein